- [Announcer] This UCSD TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language. But
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Steven] So this is a slide of some
representative fossils from about 2.8
million to 1.4 million years ago that have
been attributed to the genus Homo. And by
now you should have a pretty good idea
that we're looking at a morphologically
very diverse group of fossils. And there's
a lot of discussion about what we make of
that diversity. How many species are
represented? Which specimens go in which
species? How do we sort this all out? And
by the time that we get to specimens that
we're quite sure are Homo erectus it's not
really clear how we can trace the
ancestry. Which of these various groups
gave rise to Homo erectus? Recently
discovered fossils from South Africa have
really only kind of muddied the waters
even more. In 2010, we announced
Australopithecus sediba from roughly 2
million year old deposits of the site
called Malapa and last September we
announced Homo naledi from Rising Star.
Unfortunately, the site is currently
undated. We're working very, very hard to
try to get a date on the material, but we
do not yet know where it falls
chronologically and that makes it really,
really difficult to understand its
evolutionary relationship to other groups.
But what's interesting about these two
groups is that we now have got four
morphological groups, most of us would
call them species: Homo habilis, Homo
rudolfensis, Australopithecus sediba and
now Homo naleti which all share features
with later Homo and with Homo erectus.
They're all primitive in their own ways,
they all share derived features with Homo
erectus but they all have a different mix
and match of features and that's kind of
interesting. Again, it makes it difficult
to understand where Homo erectus came from
and that makes it difficult in turn to
figure out the evolutionary processes, the
adaptive shifts, etc. , which gave rise to
the genus Homo. When we announced
Australopithecus sediba, we were really
impressed by the number of features that
it seemed to share with later Homo and
with Homo erectus. This is a list of some
of the more important features. A lot of
these features are adaptively important
features and to us, our preferred
interpretation of this was that it meant
that sediba had an evolutionary
relationship with later Homo. We thought
that sediba was perhaps the Australopith
that had given rise to the genus Homo or a
close sister taxon to that group. A common
refrain from our colleagues in talking
about this was that the sediba was at the
wrong place at the wrong time, have
anything to do with the ancestry of the
genus Homo. Meaning, at 2 million years
it's already almost a million years later
than we're already starting to pick up
fossils of Homo in East Africa and
secondly there's sort of a general idea
that the origins of genus Homo occurred in
East Africa and here we've got a fossil
species down in southern Africa. So if in
fact sediba does not have anything to do
with the origins of the genus Homo, then
we can write off these lists of shared
features as homoplasy, as convergent
evolution. And as has already been
mentioned we know from the fossil record
that homoplasy is probably a very, very
common occurrence in evolutionary biology.
So it's probably not unreasonable to
think, maybe in fact, sediba has nothing
to do with the origins of Homo and these
are just parallel traits that have evolved
because they were adapting to similar
environments and facing similar challenges
and experiencing similar selection
pressure. There might be another good
reason to discount the species from
southern Africa from the bigger picture of
the origins of the genus Homo and that
reason is that southern Africa is a center
of mammalian endemism. It is a place where
unique species, which are only found in
southern Africa, tend to crop up. If you
look, for instance, at historically known
fauna like the quagga, unfortunately now
extinct but known in historic times, you
find this only in South Africa whereas the
plain zebra, virtual zebra extends up and
down the eastern coast of Africa and over
large parts of the continent. Over much of
Africa you've got the blue wildebeest. In
South Africa you've got the black
wildebeest. Up in most of Africa you've
got Grant's and Thomson's gazelles. In the
same ecological niche in South Africa
you've got the springbok and the springbok
isn't even closely related to Grant's and
Thomson's gazelles. This is a beautiful
case of convergence, the kind of thing
that we're talking about here. And in fact
there are 90, 90 mammalian species which
are known only from within the political
boundaries of the Republic of South
Africa. So this is clearly a center of
mammalian endemism and the mechanism that
probably has been driving this over
evolutionary time is that as global
climate waxes and wanes, as the ice ages
come and go, during the cooler, dryer
periods it's thought that a grassland
Savanna belt probably extended from the
Ethiopian highlands down to the Kalahari
desert and allowed an avenue by which
these open country forms, like the ones
that you're looking at here, were able to
migrate between geographic regions in
Africa. But then during warmer, wetter
intervals, forest spells begin to break up
that Savanna belt and in fact the Ituri
Forest here probably forms a continuous
forest with the lowlands of Mozambique and
that isolates smaller populations of these
open country forms in South Africa where
they diverge. If that's the case, then
perhaps Australopithecus afarensis appear
with sort of the pan-African wider
distributed version of an Australopith and
Australopithecus africanus down here was
the southern Africa endemic form of an
Australopith and likewise maybe
Australopithecus sediba and now Homo
naledi are just South African endemics
that have got very little to do with the
origins of genus Homo and the bigger
picture of human evolution.
Jonathan Kingdon, in his book "Island
Africa," talked about this when he said
that the centers of endemism because
unique species crop up there we tend to
think of them as evolutionary scrapyards,
as places where species originate and then
die without issue. So my goal today is to
convince you that southern Africa is not
an evolutionary scrapyard, but in fact is
important to the bigger picture of
biodiversity on the African continent and
also to say that maybe from a southern
African perspective, it might give us a
little bit of perspective on where Homo
erectus comes from. So I'm going to begin
by talking about these three antelopes.
This is the blue wildebeest up here, the
eland down here and the impala here. Based
on morphological evidence in the case of
the impala and molecular evidence for
these two antelopes, it's been argued that
in relatively recent evolutionary history,
within about the last 200,000 years, their
East African forms probably experienced
extirpation, they went locally extinct in
East Africa, and there was a repopulation
event from a South African refugium. So
these give us three examples of recent
African mammals which have spread from
southern Africa back into East Africa and
into a broader range in Africa. And the
wildebeest in particular is a member of a
tribe called the alcelaphines and the
fossil evidence suggests that the
alcelaphines are themselves a South
African endemic which originated about 7
million years ago and which now has a
distribution over much of Africa. The
quagga is also another really interesting
example. In the early days, well for most
of the time that we've known about the
quagga, it was put into its own species,
equus quagga and considered to be a
different species from the plains zebra,
equus burchelli. Plains zebras are
distributed from southern to northern
Africa as a series of subspecies from
burchell zebra down here in the south all
the way up to mainland zebra up here in
the northern part of Africa but DNA work
done on museum-preserved skins of the
quagga have strongly suggested that it is
in fact just a subspecies of the plains
zebra. So here we've got a southern
African endemic and one which at least in
terms of its pellage is quite distinct
from other zebras which is at least part
of a gene flow across the African
continent; and then of course there's
baboons. Cliff Jolly has long argued that
baboons make sort of a good model for
understanding human evolution and both
molecular and fossil data suggests that
modern baboons, of the genus Papio,
originated in southern Africa probably
like something from Papio angusticeps or
Papio ursinus or something like that and
they expanded up the Savanna corridor and
expanded into the Ethiopian highlands and
across the north of the Ituri Forest all
the way to West Africa. And then later as
the climate got warmer and wetter, that
those forest belts broke up, these groups
became isolated and they diverged into the
five species of Papio that we recognize
today. Not everybody recognizes them as
species and I'll come back to that in a
minute. So here's another example of a
possible South African endemic which is
now found with a widespread distribution
across southern Africa; but what about the
diversity that we see in the early Homo
fossil record? The diversity is important
because we've got to figure out what it
means. Does that mean that we're looking
at different species? And in fact this
specimen right here is kind of very
important to the argument. This is a
maxilla which dates to about 1.44 million
years old and is morphologically very
similar to specimens which have been put
into Homo habilis. And there are some
people who suggested, because we're
finding this morphological diversity early
in time like at 1.9 million and closer to
1.4 million, that these groups remained
morphologically distinct for long periods
of times, for half a million years. And
that suggests to some people that they
were good biological species, that they
were not exchanging genes across species
boundaries and that has big implications
for the nature of competition and the
nature of the evolution of adaptive traits
in early Homo. Well, again, if we go back
to some of these southern African
endemics, I think they give us a little
bit of a perspective on this. So if we
again look at the quagga, what's
interesting is that in a study done by
Richard Kline and Kathy Cruz-Uribe back in
1999 they showed that the skulls of the
quagga is as distinct from the skull of
the plains zebra, and remember these two
are considered now to be a subspecies of
the same species as the plains zebra is
from the Cape Mountain zebra. We know from
genetic evidence of the Cape Mountain
zebra and the plain zebra probably
diverged from one another close to 3
million years ago. So this is a case where
despite being connected by gene flow,
these two morphological groups have
remained distinct probably helped out a
bit by isolation, by distance, a bit by
some patterns or some repeated periods of
allopatry, where they got separated into
geographically distinct populations, but a
single species which is remaining
morphologically distinct over a period of
time.
And again if we go back to the baboons,
they present a really interesting case.
Some work that was done on mitochondrial
variation in the five baboon species found
that the mitochondrial genome sorted into
haplogroups, but that there was not good
phylogeographic structure to the
haplogroups; that they were a bit of a
mess and that you got some yellow baboons
mixed in with olive baboons and these
Anubis baboons in the middle of these
olive baboons, etc, etc. And the
geneticists, and there have been a number
of studies both on nuclear DNA and
mitochondrial DNA which comes to the same
conclusion, baboon genetics are a mess
because they appear to have a history of
hybridization and introgression of genes
passing between species boundaries and a
lot of people would prefer to put these
five baboons into a single species because
they do, in fact, interbreed quite freely
where they meet at hybrid zones. Other
people prefer to consider them a super
species with five distinct groups. So this
looks like a good example of a reticulate
species of some organisms which dispersed
across a geographic space, became more or
less isolated, diverged in their
morphology, their pellage, their behavior
etc, and then came back together before
that reproductive isolation was complete.
We know on average for large bodied
mammals, excluding some kind of accident
like the Oxalic acid that Pascal was
talking about we know that on average it
takes about 5 million years for large
bodied mammalian species to really become
reproductively isolated from one another.
But what's great about these baboons,
before I say what's great about them,
there's a second thing that's great about
them and that is the olive baboon. I think
he's the coolest baboon going because the
genetic evidence suggests that first off
the olive baboons originated as a hybrid
species in the contact zone between the
hamadryad baboons up here and the yellow
baboons here and that they were sort of
almost like a super baboon. They were
adaptively very competent and their range
expanded across the northern part of
Africa and they probably swallowed up
smaller pockets of baboons across that
range. And they basically, through
interbreeding with them, were able to
capture some of the genetic variations and
possibly adaptive traits from those local
populations of the baboons. So that's
really cool. But the other thing is that
we're looking at here at a species which
over 2 million years has had a history of
maybe diverging for a while and then maybe
coming back together and exchanging genes,
yet their cranial morphology remains
diagnosable. To somebody like Stephen
Frost, he can tell you, if you give him an
isolated baboon skull, whether he's
looking at an olive baboon or a chacma
baboon or yellow or Anubis. And so my
point here is that the morphological
diversity that we see in the early Homo
record, I do not think we can take that as
evidence of reproductive isolation. It's
interesting and it's interesting that it's
persisting for a long time but I don't
think that we can take it as evidence of
reproductive isolation. This is some work
that was done by Maislin and colleagues
published a couple years ago and they were
pointing out that in East Africa you have
these events which are driven by global
climatic events where the lakes in the
African Rift Valley filled up and got very
deep and they're indicated by these blue
bars here which are passing across and
they noted that after one of these events
we often pick up more diversity in the
hominin fossil records and so these are
hominin species over here on the
right-hand side and this suggests to me
that early hominins were probably relative
stenotopic, meaning they had narrow
habitat preferences. They were likely
Savanna adapted and when Savanna belts
broke up during weather conditions when
these lakes were filling up they became
relatively isolated and then after those
events we pick up new species because
we're recognizing new diversity in the
fossil record. But I don't think Homo
erectus is stenotopic. I mean Homo erectus
we pick him up in the Republic of Georgia
and very quickly after that they're
expanding into the far reaches of Asia and
that kind of thing and it makes me wonder
if Homo erectus is sort of analogous to
the olive baboon, like a super hominid it
originates out of one of these groups and
may be just because it just sort of struck
on some adaptive strategy which gave it a
wider habitat tolerance, it spread more
and it encountered other groups and
interbred with them and maybe absorbed
some of the adaptive features. And if this
is the case, then these groups out here
which we consider separate species and I
still prefer to do that although again I
argue it doesn't mean that they're
reproductively isolated, this is why we
might be seeing a pattern where they all
share different features with Homo erectus
and we may not, in fact, ever be able to
identify a single ancestor of Homo
erectus. And I think the challenge before
us is to begin to imagine new models how
do we deal with reticulate pieces. Dan
Lieberman has even talked about how we
don't really even have any methods for
recognizing hybridization even in F1
generations in the direct hybrids. And so
I think this is the challenge for us, is
to sort of figure out how we might be able
to develop and test these models.
Thank you very much
♪ [music] ♪